WE WILL SEE AS SHE DOES ANOTHER
ROUND THROUGH ROMANIA AND
POND.
WE WILL GET BACK T JUST A
NUTE.
IANT TO BRING IN BRET BAIER AS
HE HAS BEEN TRACKING THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS I UKRAINE, HE'S
BACK AT THE MAP.
>> Bret: LET'S TAK A LOOK AT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN UKRAINE
ER THE PAST 24-36 HOURS.
INCREMENTAL MOVENT BY RUSSIAN
FORCES ASE'VE SEEN, MORE
MOVEMENT TOWARDS KYIV FROM A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT AREAS, A
LITTLE MOVEMENT OUT HERE IN
KHARKIV.
WE ARE SEEING BOMBARDMENT AND A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT CITIES
ESPECIALLY AROUND KYIV, THE
SUBURBS.
BOMBARDMENT FROM THE OUTSI
BEFORE ENCIRCLING A CITY.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN FULL ENCIRCLING
YET IN MANPLACES INCLUDING
ODESSA, WE WERE EXPECTING MORE
OF A RUN ATHAT BY RUSSIAN
FORCES BUT IT HASN'T HAPPENED
YET.
AS YOU LOOK CLOSER TO KYIV, YOU
CAN SEE THESE FINGERS COMING
DOWN.
THESE ARE RUSSIAN FORCES MOVING
AND THEY ARE GETTING SUPPLIED
FROM BELARUS WITH FOOD AND FUEL.
BUT THE MAIN EFFORT IS THISBOMBN
WHICH WE HAVE SEEN AROD THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IS A CLOSER LOOK AT KYIV.
THIS IS DOWNTOWN, THESE GLO
ARE RUSSIAN FORCES INTRUDING BUT
THEY ARE SEEING A LOT OF
UKRAINIAN DEFENSE AND AOT OF
PUSHBACK BY UKRAINIAN FORCES.
IN FACT THOUSANDSND THOUSANDS
OFUSSIAN SOLDIERS ACCORDING TO
U.S. INTELLIGENCE HAVE ALREADY
DIED IN THIS CONFLICTND THAT
IS TAKING ITS TOLL.
WE HAVE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE NUCLEAR FACITIES,
CHERNOBYL IN THEORTH CUT OFF
TO ELECTCITY.
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN IN T
HEAT COU BUILD UP THERE AND
RADIOACTIVITY ULD LEAK OUT.
RADIATION, RHER -- THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED.
THE IAEA SAYS THEY ARE CONVINCED
THAT NUCLEAR EXPERTS THE
RUSSIANS ARE CONTROLLING THIS
PARTICULAR FACILITY.
THERE AR A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
REACTORS THRGHOUT THE COUNTRY
THAT ARE OF CONCERN.
IN THE SOUTH THE MOST ACTIVITY
WE HAVE SEEN IS UP HERE IN
MARIUPOL.
WE SAW THOSE HORRIFIC
BOMBARDMENTS IN THE MATERNITY
HOSPAL EARLIER TODAY.
SOME MOVEMENT BY RUSSIANORCES
THIS WAY WE EXPECT IT'S GOING TO
GO DN TO THE PORT CY OF
ODESSA.
THIS SO FAR HAS NOT BEE
TOUCHED, THERE HASN'T BEENHIS
LANDING THAT WAS SUSPECTED TO
TAKE THE PORT CITY AS OF YET.
THE PEOPLE IN ODEA, WE'VE SEEN
VIDEO  THEM BARRICADING AND
BUILDING UP AND TRAINING,
GETTING READY FOR A BIG FIGHT
THERE.
UKRAINIAN FORCES HOLDING VY
STEADY ON THIS.
MARIUPOL, JUNE 21ST.
TH IS A SHOPPING CENTER, CARS
PARKED OUT HERE, A
GROCERY STE.
JUST LIKE YOU WOULD E IN ANY
U.S. CITY.
BUT THE BOMBARDMENT HAS BEEN
INTENSE D THERE YOU SEE THE
REACTION OR THE AFTERMATH THIS
SHOPPING CENRAKEN OUT BY A
CRUISE MISSILE OR A BOMB AS WELL
AS THIS GROCERY STORE.THESE AREM
THAT MATERNITY HOSPITATHAT WE
SAW HIT.
IN THAT HOSPITAL, AMAZINGLY ONLY
17 PEOPLE INJURED, NO O DIED
TO PICK UP DEATHS ARE TAKING UP.
CIVILIANS, MILITARY, AND RUSSIAN
MILITARY AS THIS INSURGENCY
LOOKS LIKE IS GOING TO LAST
FOR QUITE SOME TIME